says the congressman hunted by a press
looking into his past well guys
there's a back story based in fiction
because the CV that propelled him here
doesn't add up they're not almost daily
Revelations of false claims a drip feet
of Deceit in this the seat of power the
George Santos story doesn't sit well
this campaign was never about me Santos
the candidate claimed he wanted Finance
Giants Citigroup and Goldman Sachs they
say he didn't he said his mother was in
the World Trade Center during 9 11 and
claimed his grandparents fled the
Holocaust I am the grandchild of
Holocaust Survivors and the son of a 911
Survivor the evidence indicates both
claims are false when questioned Santos
said he's never claimed to be Jewish
only Jew H and then there's his
education he said he graduated from
Baruch College it says it has no record
of him that despite his spin on sporting
achievement he claims to have been a
star of the volleyball team Richard
ostoff features in the Santos Story the
Navy veteran claims the politician
pocketed three thousand dollars that was
raised to treat Sapphire his pit bull
terrier Santos denies it I was so livid
that I realized that this guy is now a
serving congressman
then there is Qatar of Ash or George
Santos in drag performers in Brazil say
this is him Santos himself says he just
had fun at a festival
more recent pictures reflect his
alignment with the extremist wing of the
Republican Party the openly gay
Congressman has supported policies seen
as discriminatory against the lgbtq
community The Campaign Of The Sea lies
fabrication his local Long Island party
wanted to step down in Washington he
faces investigations surrounding his
campaign finances but senior Republicans
are standing by him they can't afford to
lose his seat Mr Santos do your lies
make a mockery of this place and of the
American people
what would it take for you to resign Mr
Santos pardon me guys
is the Republican is the Republican
Party tainted by your fabrication sir
appreciate it good to see you should the
public believe anything you say thank
you James Matthews Sky News in
Washington